on est en train d'avancer massivement
sur la vaccination et les indicateurs
continuent à baisser malgré le fait
qu'on y alors sa dernière par des hommes
que tout sépare
malgré le fait qu'on est desserré les
mesures de restriction et la dernière
mais voit répondre au bel éphèbe mettre
des vidéos aujourd'hui vous redevenez
condescendant méprisant et donneur de
leçon je voulais l'attrait françois
fecteau fabrique sur le respecte mais la
très franchement vous nous annoncez de
manière péremptoire et c'est dangereux
parce qu'il ya quelques pourcentage
infime mais quand même quelques
pourcentage de la population qui vous
crois hélas c'est dangereux parce que je
voyais ma démonstration
j'ai encore pas mal de danse refusé mois
d'essai moi je suis les rues de secondes
expliqué je fais ça parole juste après
les voyez c'est un peu ça qui nous
différencie c'est que moi j'ai encore
une infime partie de la population qui
me croient vous c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
un quart des bâtards de fabrice alors
que tu dis ah ça moi je dis que moi
étant pas donner de leçons et quand vous
dites
alko couvre-feu c'est criminel ce que
vous dites les gens les gens déjà ne
respectent pas les 21h vous savez très
bien le sens paris ça se relâchent si
vous dites vous halte au couvre-feu
les gens vont ressortir 23 heures non
mais j'y là là dessus j'adore chris carr
a vraiment pris ce cas d'accord mais je
suis d'accord a eu un bris sur le court
for intérieur ça favorise une chaussée
les audiences télé non mais franchement
je vous dis la vérité
au plan d'eau où 169 j'en sais pas où je
les connais pas du tout respectée
puisque un bail
il est maintenant je suis pas d'accord
quad et j'en tire à sa fin car il est y
compris à des personnes qui ne
respectent pas mais une large majorité
le respecte et le sujet encore une fois
c'était de ne pas ouvrir de manière trop
rapide et de chrysler maintenant vous
l'évaluez je voulais avez vous voulez
même si on dit la majorité de respect
comment voulez value mais il faut
regarder ça mais madame vous avez vous
dit quelque chose c'est comme normal
qu'on puisse s'en allait battre français
frère le mans a tout d un système vous
je vivais vous regardez ce sens de l'udc
couvre-feu bon mais le fait pas vous
mais j'ai donc bon je respecte tout le
temps ce n'est pas non mais c'est
intéressant ce guide vous voyez c'est ça
que je reproche aux uns et aux autres
vous parlez par affirmation vous avez
employé ce mot opérant de toi c'est vous
qu'êtes péremptoire parce que vous
parlez d envoi après 21h mais enfin et
jersey moi monsieur verdez mais très
sérieusement des gens nous regardent le
minimum qu'on leur doit verser un
minimum de vérité vous n'avez que le
couvre-feu 21h ceci le batteur cela mais
donnez moi des élément tempérant sinon
c'est du dogme et de la religion
avez vous des éléments à ce sujet
l'épidémiologie monsieur respecté et que
celle et dangereuse que d'être
péremptoire le problème de fond est
toujours le même de ce que ça veut dire
donc même vous estimez que finalement
j'ai un mur et les restrictions ont
aggravé la situation sanitaire de je
pense que je n'en je pense des plaies
encore une fois c'est là vous vous
trompez la différence de vous c'est que
moi je pense rien a déjà dealé pas ici
pour nous lâcher
non mais attendez je cherche et quand je
cherche vous n'avez vous que j'ai
quelque chose à lui reprocher ressent et
les français nous avons une étude que
j'ai déjà publié ici il faudra vraiment
que je pense à vous les envoyez l'on
irait bien c'est à dire jeudi à la prod
que ce serait bien effectivement vous
aviez les études je pensais que c'était
fait mais apparemment pas sur le fait ça
mais ça coûte cher c'est peut-être rien
mais qu'est ce qu'il a prouvé vous eh
bien je retourne la question - turenne
autorisé la parole ouais nan ça parce
que j'ai pas on pose une question
j'essaie d'apprendre on fait basique
fabrice ce que j'essaye de vous dire
c'est que ça s'appelle l'effet pâte à
modeler je voulais déjà dit que je
voulais gagner restreint les gens les
gens continuent de vivre quand même
d'accord donc qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
font des fêtes clandestines
ils font effectivement ils se réunissent
quand même et vous n'avez plus aucune
mesure de ce qui se passe est fait vous
n'avez absolument plus qu'un compte les
nouvelles ce qui se passe